un mot pour vous dire que le tournage
des séries rupture et blum houde
reprendra d'ici la fin de la semaine
après l'arrêt de travail
peut-être vous le savez vous avez suivi
son cours des derniers jours de quatre
jours jacques bissonnet les productions
de fabienne larouche et le syndicat des
techniciens se sont entendus pour
ajuster assouplir les conditions de
travail sur les plateaux tout à fait
mais le syndicat se plaignait depuis
plusieurs jours d'une surcharge de
travail sur ces deux productions nombre
de la production et production et thiès
de fabienne larouche
alors selon le syndicat et c'est la vie
également de l'union des artistes
c'est la réduction des budgets sur ces
mini série au québec sur les séries
télévisées qui entraîne ce surcroît de
travail
alors ça a été le cas en ce qui concerne
ces deux productions de laumont des
ruptures et c'est aussi selon l'union
des artistes
le cas pour d'autres productions
québécoises mais dans ce cas-ci pour ces
deux productions
ça s'est réglé parce que les
négociations au cours du week-end et cet
après midi ils en sont venus à une
entente
alors c'est réglé comme nous l'indiquent
ici le directeur général du syndicat des
techniciens a déjà le nombre de journées
de tournage mais ça fait en sorte que
les journées sont très condensée et très
intense lorsque tu travailles beaucoup
plus de seins dans même journée beaucoup
plus de déplacements pour réaliser les
différentes scènes qui en fait donc
c'était là l'essentiel des choses
alentours de sauna
et là c'est réglé à la satisfaction de
tout le monde voilà et puis à cette
triste histoire de ce technicien le 30
août dernier qui a fait un accident de
voiture il allait porter ou aller
chercher dieu des repas bref la csst à
qui on a demandé d'ouvrir une enquête va
ouvrir une enquête ou écouter le
cotonnier le cantonnier en fait donc de
cette production rupture qui s'appelle
caoutchouc man and 34 ans a été
gravement blessé dans cet accident de
voiture survenu dans le tunnel
ville-marie le 30 août dernier
alors selon ce qu'on a plus aujourd'hui
c'est que des enquêteurs de la csst ont
commencé leur travail ils ont rencontré
des gens des productions et tyrosse
également du syndicat des techniciens
on verra leur rapport ce sera sans doute
pas pour demain ça pourrait prendre
plusieurs jours et même plus davantage
sans doute
merci jacques zoua prix avant